our next guest is making headlines for
not only being a mom
but a respiratory therapist working on
the front lines during the cove
19 pandemic uh she's also a firefighter
too
yeah let's just throw that in there you
have to check out her story take a look
at this
my name is jennifer kingsbury and i'm 30
years old i live in abington
pennsylvania i like to joke that i am
the most social kermit you will ever
meet
i am employed as a respiratory therapist
and i have been a firefighter with the
abbington fire company for four years
in addition to wife i'm also a mom to a
new two-year-old
my husband and i have been married for
six years he's been a firefighter for
eight
and he's inspired me to join as well
four years ago i was looking for ways to
help out of my community
and decided to take an accelerated
course to become a firefighter
so my work days are very long i have to
wake up at 5 30 in the morning
to leave and i don't get home until
after 8 so unfortunately
my baby's asleep when i leave and when i
get home since we're always on call
there are nighttime calls sometimes at
midnight sometimes at three in the
morning and you just
get up you get dressed and you do the
best that you can
being so busy with long work days and on
call with the fire department i
definitely need to find some time for
myself
when i'm overwhelmed i can step away
from work
um and i can also take a break from the
fire service but
i'm always will call the mother
oh jennifer kingsbury
hello thank you for having me on the
show
i mean i care so much about other people
but when i hear your story
you do you make me feel like a slacker
and i mean that in the best way ever
and you're such an inspiration i heard
your husband
was a firefighter like he inspired you
right to get
into the action yes my husband has been
a firefighter for about eight years and
we're very family oriented so i spent a
lot of time at the firehouse doing
family activities
or using their free gym and one day i
just decided you know what
i want to join too i was looking for
volunteer opportunities and they're very
flexible
so i joined the fire company and what
about being a nurse was there anything
that inspired you for that
i've always been interested in things in
medicine
and kids so when i started out as a
therapist eight years ago i specialized
in neonatal care
which is hard it's heartbreaking but
it's so fulfilling
i recently transitioned to adult care i
work at a level one trauma center in
philadelphia
so that's great as well and at the same
time i decided to become a firefighter
so this was all four years ago
transitioning from children to adults
being a firefighter
it was just a fun time of change and
then you have this beautiful two and a
half year old
what do you do to after you give to your
child you give
as a respiratory therapist you give as a
firefighter you give as a wife and
probably in no such order on every given
day
what do you do for yourself do you have
something
you know i love to garden and i've been
gardening pre-covered
so you just carve out a little time for
yourself when you can whether it's late
at night after bedtime or taking
advantage of nap time
that's my time to say okay jen here's a
cup of coffee
here's a good book or i sneak away to my
garden
and when was the last time you had like
a date night
oh my gosh we don't know what date night
is um
we managed to sneak away back in
december my mom was able to watch the
baby for a couple of hours so
we went toy shopping and we snuck in a
nice little lunch date and it was
amazing
wow we had a baby moon planned but that
didn't really work out because hurricane
florence destroyed that
well jennifer i know that you've been
just
working overtime and really just showing
us all
what is possible uh for one human being
to do and you
serve and protect your community in so
many ways
especially during this last year
and you put yourself last in so many
ways and that's what we do as moms
that's the sign up that's the job
but then the way you over extend
yourself for everyone else too it's just
it's awe-inspiring and we all here at
the show
thought you deserved a break so uh
i want to give you a mom's time out so
we're gonna send you and your husband
on a luxurious six night seven day stay
in a beachfront room at the
intercontinental
fiji golf resort and spa that's right
it's in fiji and
it's on the majestic beachfront of the
um
natandola bay on fiji's mainland and
your resort
like there has a round-trip transfer
that'll be provided by rosie holidays
fiji and then our friends at fiji airway
the national airline of fiji are going
to provide you
with the round-trip tickets so
everything is dialed in
and taken care of but most importantly
we made sure with your mom
and she's gonna watch your little one
it's all been thought of it's all been
taken care of
um this is just for you to enjoy and
relax
as soon as it is safe this is just
waiting for you
i don't know how to say it but thank you
that's all i can say i know my husband's
going to enjoy it so we really
appreciate it
i can't think of all the things that you
deserve in this world for being so good
to everyone
else and jennifer i mean really
you're amazing thank you thank you
i want to hear all about it by the way
will you please tell us how it went
oh i will be sure to write and let you
guys know it's
gonna be great okay great thank you
thank you thank you to your mom who's
holding down the fart